I'm so thrilled to be sitting here with
basketball legend and all-around cool
cat Shaquille Shaq O'Neal Pete Johnson
thank you very much graduates on the new
show homes oh sorry
I mean we only that's right step
together need to hang out and write
together what's your favorite swear
favorite swear I don't swear on TV let's
pretend we're not on TV I'll tell you
what I'll say just let me give my sensor
up this is what I would say if I went on
TV that's what I was finishing right
midnight I didn't see I didn't see
Kazaam I'm graduating see design did you
like Kazan
I loved it especially when they paid me
all that money they paid me to play Jack
man in a few inches how much cash do you
have on you right now $1 that's a lie
cause you know why why I have facial
recognition see this face Waffle House
free Walmart free RadioShack free well
yeah and Dairy Queen with the sprinkles
free paint this face face is a coupon
that's right
let's you hand the hand that's a big
hand you can curse on you so that's what
I'm saying what's your favorite curse on
the 66 that's considered quite large and
you're not regular your big big bottle I
could open you like a cello case and
sleep inside
actually no you go I was totally good I
don't wanna be in your belly bang style
I don't want you to sleep inside me
because it's um to mix alright so just
change the subject for knock you up we
don't have a lot of time that's all
right ask whatever you want people ever
think you're just a bunch of kids in a
trench coat
don't you agree how far do you think you
could he've me about 20 feet
like Pete you're lighter mass who would
win in a fight you were a shark me what
if the shark was drunk me thank you so
much Shaq Shake Shack finish a kit
anytime buddy say back see a few feet
that's me future please future Pete back
to you Pistol Pete indent future back to
you fuchsia pink back to you future Pete
all right